[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
to all the french who chose to abstain
or the vote on the extreme either
because they're angry faced with
persistent inequality a damaged planet
everyday insecurity the difficulty to
make a decent living despite working
hard
i want to convince them in the coming
days your vote depends all over the
french territory on the legitimate
preponderance of the french culture and
language the customs of our regions and
the french way of life on republican
laws and values
factory
[Music]
my
after the presidential election we will
have the parliament elections it's
totally polarized we have now three
blocks we have a leftist block with mr
melancho who got a very good score much
more than the a little more than the
poll predicted it we have the the block
with mr macron and we have the far right
block so we have three blogs the
traditional parties like the socialist
party or the right parties have nearly
disappeared so we don't know what will
be the future for them it's a big worry
for the militants it's a big worry for
the political leaders of these two
traditional parties the socialist and
the right